-This is very exciting.
Just announced that you're one
of the moderators for thes
two debates that are coming up
We knew the debates
were coming up.
We didn't know the moderators.
But we do know that it's going
to be two nights,
ten candidates each night.
-Doubleheader.
-With ten teams playing
each other on both nights.
-And this must be --
I would imagine, you know,
campaign moderating prep
is hard to begin with,
but you -- This isn't like
you have to do a book report
This is like you have to d
a book report on all the books
-The funny thing is, like,
we start getting in
debate prep materials,
and it's like,
"Here's your booklet
on Cory Booker."
Oh, fascinating. I've
interviewed Cory Booker before
This is going to be great.
"And here's your booklet
on Elizabeth Warren."
Okay, cool.
"And Steve Bullock
and Michael Bennet
and Marianne Williamson
and Andrew Yang."
And there's 23 books.
-Yeah.
-And then, so, you start to,
like, think your way out of it
You're like,
"Well, do I have to read
the book on each one of the 23?"
Yes, because it will be the on
that I thought I could skimp o
who will have a breakout moment,
and I'll be like,
"That was amazing, Denise.
She'll be like,
"My name isn't Denise!"
How do you prepare to not only
understand all 20 of them,
but to understand the potentia
interactions between them?
-And I don't know -- You
probably know this better
than me, because we don't know
which ten are going to be on
which night.
Because that's like
random lottery draw?
-So, the DNC --
Thank God, not us.
It is the DNC who decides,
of the Democratic candidates
which 20 make the cut.
-Yeah.
So three as of now, three --
We don't know
if more people join the race
but three will be on the outside
looking in.
-Unless more candidates
join the race
between now
and the end of the week,
in which case,
there might even be more.
-So they either want three
to drop out or seven to join
-Yes. Do a third night. Exactly.
But then, once they've got the
20, then they have to decide
how they get allocated between
the two different nights.
And again, thank God,
not, like, me
and the other moderators
who have to decide that.
The DNC will do it, and I thin
that will be some sort of
random draw or something.
But whatever happens, all hell
is going to break loose.
-You mentioned breakout moments,
and I want to ask about that
because it seems --
It strikes me,
based on the way you do
your show, you are --
will be hopeful
for organic conversation
and, yet,
it always seems at debates
that you can tell when someone
has like a preplanned,
prepackaged moment that
they want to get out there
as their breakout moment
in the debate.
Is there any way around that
-To warn them right now
that they shouldn't do that?
I mean, that's the thing.
Any time somebody has rehearse
their moment, you know --
"I will look concerned,
then appear surprised,
then raise my index finger
then appear to be naturall
and organically outraged
in the moment, and then
wait for my applause."
Like, those moments,
those canned moments
never, ever, ever, ever work
-Yeah.
-But I can't imagine
that they're not all
going to plan one.
-It does seem like audiences
now, or I should say voters now,
have a better sense
for authenticity.
And one thing you have to sa
about Donald Trump,
he is authentically himsel
and was at every debate.
Like, there was never a time
where he was like,
"Oh, I have to get
to my preplanned line."
They were just like -- I don't
think he preplans anything
-"Got to make sure
I get the details
of this policy just right.
That didn't happen.
-I think inside, he's like
"I think I'm going to
throw up some word soup."
-"See? It sticks.
I told you it would stick.
No puppet, no puppet.
You're the puppet."
Yes. I mean, the candidate
right now are in the stage
of the Democratic primary
where they're not, like,
being mean to each other.
They're not taking
each other down.
And I think lots of people
who want Donald Trump
to lose the general election
hope that the Democratic primary
stays like that forever.
-Right.
They're always
so mutually supportive.
I mean, ultimately,
the Democratic primary
should be a hard-fought,
knock-down, drag-out contest
because you want
whoever gets to the genera
to be tough and to have
proven themselves
against really difficult
criticism,
even unfair criticism, because
you know what it's going to be
like to run against Trump.
It's like running
against a blender.
-Yeah, I do think that --
Absolutely.
And that is a counter-argument
to this idea
that we all need to be nic
to each other.
It's not like Donald Trump needs
another Democratic candidate
to point out a flaw in somebod
that he might one day
run against,
because he's very good
at finding flaws,
even things that aren't true
-Yes.
-So he doesn't need any help
from, you know, Cory Booker to
tell him something he can make
fun of Pete Buttigieg about.
-Well, yes,
and, I mean, honestly,
if you look at history in term
of the modern
presidential contests,
almost always
when there's a big field
that has really robust
competition --
not every time,
but almost every time --
the candidate from that part
tends to win.
Because primaries
that are hard to win
make you a better candidate.
-Yeah.
-And all of these candidates -
I mean, all of the Democrats
are interesting.
I mean, I think
almost all of them
would make
really good presidents.
They've all had
interesting careers.
They're all --
I've met almost all of them.
They're all interesting people
They're all competent.
But I don't know which of them
would make the best president.
And the best way I know to fin
out is to see them battle it out
within an inch of their live
with all the other people
who might conceivably
be president, too.
So, I mean, what is the lesson
of Hillary Clinton
versus Donald Trump
in terms of how to beat hi
in a general election?
I don't think
anybody has any idea.
I think it's got to be
something new.
-The other thing that's going to
be fascinating to watch is
based on how voters --
the feedback the first night o
those ten people debating --
the feedback from that night
how it affects the way
that people will debate
the next night.
If everybody says,
"Oh, it was a little boring,
'cause everybody
was so friendly,"
you might have the knives ou
right away on night two.
Which would be fascinating
to watch
and what makes this year
so interesting
because there's so many people
-But, I mean,
the other idea, too, is just -
Okay, it's two hours for eac
of those two nights.
There's ten candidates
on the stage
for those entire two hours
plus there has to be some time
like, for the questions
to be asked.
I mean, how many minutes
are each of them going to get?
And for somebody like, you know,
Joe Biden or Bernie Sanders,
who's doing really well
in the polls,
do you essentially
just want to lie low
and hopefully nobody notices you
and you can keep riding
your name recognition?
-I feel like Bernie
is very bad at that.
-[ Laughs ] Lying low?
-Yeah, lying low.
"I'm just going to stand her
and not be noticed!!"
I want to talk real quick --
Before we go to commercial
I want to talk about this idea
about electability.
Everybody's talking
And I think when you go back
to our last two presidents
neither of them
seemed at all electable
until they were president.
-Yeah.
-You know, I mean --
-Even in retrospect,
they don't seem like it.
-You know, but there was -- Yo
know, we obviously never elected
a black man president unti
President Barack Obama,
and we never elected whateve
it is that Donald Trump is
He's the first of it.
He's the first of his kind
So what -- Do you think people
are too caught up in it,
or do you think it is just
this sort of core fear
of the Democratic Party
right now
not to have the same outcome
-I think it's both
totally understandable
and also a fool's errand.
I mean, I think that Democrats
looking at their field right now
probably see a lot
that they like in that field
I mean, if there's something
that you don't like
about one of the candidates,
there's 22 others
to choose from.
And there's plenty --
There's plenty there on offer.
I think the unifying thing
that does motivate all Democrats
and a lot of independents
right now
is the desire to get Trump
out of there.
That's just going to be
the dominating factor
in a field this big.
It's really, therefore, hard not
to approach the primary proces
as something
you ought to game out
in terms of who's
most electable.
The problem with that
is that nobody can tell,
and when you try to make
your voting decision
based on not who you think
is your favorite candidate
but who you think everybody else
might think is their
favorite candidate,
it's just dumb game theory
It just doesn't work
mathematically.
The best thing you can do fo
your country in the primar
is, A, pay attention,
B, commit to vote,
and, C, vote for the perso
you think would make
the best president.
Any other way
you try to outthink it,
you're going to undo
the point of the process.
-Well, I hope we get a ste
closer after the debates.